Last year here at Comic Con,
we had an unexpected guest drop in on us.
It did not go well, I'll be honest,
he was booed off the stage, now he has demanded
to come back and visit again.
This year, he's flown in directly from his
top secret lair and golf club in Mar-a-Lago,
please welcome, Captain Make America Great Again.
Hello everybody, wow!
Look at this!
Hello everybody, how are you?
Good to see you.
Hello everyone, thank you Conan
and, and, please, please, please...
Correction: I am now, no longer
Captain Make America Great Again.
I am President Captain Make America Great Again.
(audience booing)
Wow!
Wow, listen to those woos, they're going nuts.
Sir, I gotta be honest with you,
I don't think those are woos.
Oh sure they are, that's how these nerds cheer.
(audience booing louder)
I have had the greatest cheer of any
superhero in the history of superheroes ever, #ever.
Okay well, you know who's having
a even bigger year, Wonder Woman.
I'll be honest with you, Wonder Woman.
(audience cheering)
No, no, excuse me, excuse me.
I do not want to talk about crooked Wonder Woman, Conan.
Alright?
She is a low energy loser.
(audience boos)
There she is.
What are you talking about?
She has the number one superhero movie this year.
(audience cheering)
Please, alright, I have proof
there is widespread viewer fraud.
That sounds like one of your crazy conspiracy theories.
I don't like her alright, she walks around
with that lasso of truth, keep
that thing away from me, Conan.
I can see why you might have a problem with that.
And you know what else I don't like?
San Diego.
[Conan] Oh my god.
(audience booing)
This time of year, the entire town
smells like Jabba the Hutt died inside of a fish taco.
Come on, come on...
(audience booing)
Boo him all you want, that was a good one.
Wait, wait, wait, if you hate it so much,
why'd you come back?
Well, my son wanted to check out Comic Con
for his 40th birthday, come on out,
Captain Make America Junior.
(audience booing)
Look at him, now that is a high quality person,
he looks tremendous.
Junior...
(audience laughin)
Junior, Junior...
Are you enjoying Comic Con, Captain America Great
Again Junior, are you enjoying it?
Oh yeah, this morning, I went to a private
panel in room 823 at the Downtown Weston.
Okay, I'm sorry, that's confusing.
A private panel in a hotel room?
Yes, it was just me and Captain Russia,
Vodka Man and Anna Kournikova.
I told you to stay in the car, you idiot.
Conan, we've got to go.
Well, thank you very much for stopping in,
you guys really lifted our spirits.
We are leaving San Diego.
Just like The Chargers, Hail Hydra.
Okay.
(dramatic music)
You really wanna punch that son, don't ya.